[Musique]
alors des images de monsieur gautier qui
arrive avec son convoi de la côte nord
c'est des images presque en direct à
stoneham c'est là où on va passer la
nuit pour plusieurs des manifestants
pour l'instant disons le il n'y a pas
foule il ya du monde n'y a pas foule on
verra
voilà stéphanie grammond michel david
martin biron bonsoir bonsoir je vais
passer un autre ville tout de suite pour
viendra québec après parce que hier la
police d'ottawa disait c'est clairement
nous on pense pas que c'est une
opération policière qui doit résoudre ça
c'est un problème national donc d'où
l'idée de l'armée voyez ce que monsieur
trudeau a répondu aujourd'hui
qu'il est temps que les manifestants
rentrent chez eux nous savons que les
forces policières que ce soit la police
d'ottawa ou à la grc qui a les
ressources souci est là pour régler la
situation et entend gouvernement nous
allons être là pour répondre à des
demandes formelles ou bien de la ville
d'ottawa ou bien de la province ils ont
besoin de plus de ressources
mais pour l'instant c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on est en train de regarder
d'envoyer les forces armées contre des
citoyens canadiens pas question
d'envoyer l'armée la stéphanie tour de
table ottawa comment vous voyez la suite
des choses mais certainement qu'on
souhaite qu' il ya une une issue
pacifique à tout ça et qu'on soit pas
obligé d'amener l'armée dans le décor je
pense que les manifestations oui
d'accord tout le monde le droit de
manifester ça fait partie de la
démocratie mais assiégée une ville c'est
une autre histoire et tous les gestes
qu'on a vu le depuis une semaine c'est
quand même inacceptable donc on peut pas
laisser
250 personnes même si les ondes et des
gros camions et des gros bras on peut
pas les laisser pendant en otage le
parlement et il ya 17 millions
d'électeurs qui ont voté aux élections
aussi longtemps et qui ont élu monsieur
trudeau et que ça plaise ou non à ses
250 personnes là ils font pas le poids
ils peuvent pas arriver comme ça demande
et tout est rien et il est passé me
compris que monsieur trudeau s'en aille
et là mais je n'avais les martin jeu on
se lance la balle un peu la police
d'ottawa du coup tu es là tout ça nous
dépasse toujours dit je vais quand même
pas envoyé l'armée contre des canadiens
la grc trouve pas de deux remorqueurs
qui accepteraient de d'enlever des
collègues et un bref on s'en va où le
chef d'abord je pense qu'il faudrait
avoir un fondement légal à une
quelconque expulsions alors il ya un
processus on peut demander une
injonction faut qu'elle soit basée sur
quelque chose et à partir de ce moment
là les forces de l'ordre sont mandatés
pour exécuter les décisions d'un
tribunal à ce que je sache on n'est pas
vendu encore à cette étape que je pense
que les incontournables maintenant et
les camionneurs j'ai l'impression
ce comprend que des éléments extrême et
extrémistes qui ont dans une analyse
différente de celle du commun des
mortels mais il y avait une certaine
sympathie dans la population au départ
d'une partie de la population on dirait
mais
disparaît la vitesse de l'éclair cité
cette série pas d'ici là et je pense
qu'à un moment donné tout ce que
j'espère qu'ils vont saisir mon vélo ce
qu'on a fait ce qu'on avait à démontrer
ces faits là
et on savoir qu'on entend une mère j'ai
lu ça sur notre site soit je voulais
qu'on en parle plutôt une mère qui dit
j'ai pas pu le rendez-vous monfils est
cancéreux il avait juin et là tu dit
martin de là ça suffit non c'est sûr que
moi je pense que le compte à rebours est
parti il va on va voir aussi l'exemple
de ce qui va se passer en fin de semaine
à québec
mais là il ya des gens du quartier qui
commencent à manifester à s'organiser
faire d'une manifestation contre une
manifestation il ya des gens qui sont
dans des situations c'est difficile le
code de la mer qui va emmener son enfant
l'hôpital et on ne peut pas on peut pas
faire autrement que d'être sympathique à
cette situation alors et il va commencer
il y en avoir d'autres situations comme
ça alors il risque de se retrouver avec
un noyau de plus en plus petit
essai j'ai l'impression comptable un peu
là dessus même si l'image va falloir
qu'il est fatigué fasse sortir de l'eau
excusez moi même si les images d'un des
citoyens qui ont qui feront manifesté à
leur tour devant les mains du festin
goran time to go wrong dubaï hockey
québec québec alors avec l'exemple de
tahoua et peut-être qu'on parle de
québec finalement on va dire demain
après demain vous savez vous où il y
avait à peu près personne mais quand
même on se prépare écoutez toute la
classe politique qui dit venez pas faire
du grabuge chez nos
collègues ou que
parfaitement paie sage le premier
ministre a envoyé d'abord il peut être
l'air alors une manifestation pacifique
oui jamy québec pendant des semaines
n'ont demandé la levée des mesures
sanitaires
si manifester contre la solidarité puis
le nom de notre parti c'est quoi ces
québec solidaire
je veux pas non plus qu'on alimente la
polarisation à 10 ans il ya des
mauvaises manifestations ont leur salut
de ce soir ou demain on demande à ces
gens là de se comporter avec civisme
gabriel nadeau-dubois ce qu'un ami rené
ce
qui fait un peu la morale à d'autres
manifestants il ya il ya quand même bloc
n comme de rue lui des jeunes oui oui
c'est arrivé puis oui tout le monde je
pense a été un peu surpris de cette
intervention alors monsieur nadeau
dubois et
je pense pas que ce soit à lui ni à qui
que ce soit de le décider quelle est la
bonne cause italie la mauvaise cause le
droit de manifester il a oublié pas là
non je pensais pas sa manière très
certainement maintenant je pense que
d'abord sur le plan logistique on a dû
tirer les leçons de tahoua je pense pas
qu'on va permettre aux camions de venir
bloquer la colline parlementaire on va
essayer les garder un peu en périphérie
j'imagine et je pense que
tout en fait tous les discours le conte
attendant la population depuis quelques
jours le carnaval les enfants
j'ai l'impression que les manifestants
enfin moi j'ai cette impression que je
me trompe mais que ça sera pas aussi
gros qu'un ce qu'on croit que les
messages ont été entendus que les gens
veulent pas
le jour du carnaval domaine mettre la
ville à metal les prêts seront menacés
que les policiers québec qu'ils ont tiré
des leçons de ce qu'ils ont observé à
ottawa alors ils laisseront pas les
camionneurs se rendent directement sur
le terrain de la colline parlementaire
et déjà au tour le devant la colline
parlementaire il ya des barricades de ce
plaisir que je peux pas mon poste
actionner carrément sur le terrain de la
colline parlementaire est question
confort aussi des rues etc on confine
finalement les camionneurs seulement sur
rené lévesque lé pour ceux qui
connaissent l'endroit les policiers sont
là ils vont être là et monsieur legault
a fait la classe politique au complet
vraiment envoyer un signal de cale l'on
sait pas on ne sait pas s'ils ont deux
chaises
comme d'autres politiciens offerte à moi
ils l'ont payé cher cela dit mais ici
tout le monde est unanime et respecter
les règles c'est pour ça qu'on a un peu
l'impression que ça dure pas longtemps
le sur tout les restaurateurs aussi
sortent là pour dire bah écoutez moi
c'est mon premier week end sur grande
allée puis j'ai plus d'annulations que
de deux rendez-vous de réservation alors
dans le but de la manifestation c'est ça
c'est la levée des mesures sanitaires
bon mais attendons ses fans et un petit
bout mais attendons je sais pas
oui c'est ça parce que là je pense que
la sympathie du public pour ces gens-là
s'amenuisent énormément le
grand martyr mais finalement et il ya
des gens qui sont parfois les plus
malmenées que par la pandémie n'a des
gens qui sont à l'hôpital et qui peuvent
pas avoir d'opération et les
travailleurs de la santé chez terra donc
ils ont pas ces gens là ou pas le
monopole du ras-le-bol sanitaire donc je
pense que c'est en serrant les coudes et
en respectant les mesures qu'on peut
arriver à passer par deux chez les
syndiqués m'bengue mais encore une fois
le droit de manifester en démocratie
c'est sacré alors manifestés mais ces
organes pas manifestés et tout bloquer
on change de sujet la langue le
gouvernement de monsieur legault s'était
engagé avait dit que c'était une
priorité de donner de l'argent pour
agrandir le cégep d'arsène à montréal
cégep anglophone qui accueille aussi des
francophones évidemment le parti
québécois a toujours été contestée une
histoire qui roule est un peu là sur la
go diab est très bien on financera paul
cgem tu as ça je vous mets un contexte
autre sujet linguistique le minerai
barrette qui voulaient pas qu'on impose
le bilinguisme chez les juges à perdre
une manche hier alors ça s'y retrouver à
l'assemblée nationale dans un mélange
une confrontation que je vous fait
écouter
concernant d'hassen le président la chef
de l'opposition officielle touche pas
surpris nous dit que ce serait
prioritaire pour l d'agrandir les cégeps
anglophones avant des cégeps
francophones dans sun c'est son
gouvernement qu'il a priorisé c'est son
gouvernement qui a voulu accélérer dans
le projet de loi 76 qui l'a mis de
l'avant monsieur le président comment un
appel un francophone qui étudie à dawson
50 % seulement des étudiants qui étudia
dorson sont des anglophones donc comment
on appelle des étudiants qui étudia
dawson la moitié c'est pas des
anglophones pour reprendre que le
premier ministre me disais tantôt
quelqu'un 1 l'expression anglaise kate à
saint-girons est-ce qu'il estime qu'il a
le droit d'être défendu dans sa langue
maternelle quand j'entends la chef du
parti libéral dit savez monsieur le
québécois monsieur président
ileka qu'est ce que ça vous dit ce
président si on se répète les propos du
premier ministre de l'opposition en fait
une erreur en vous appelant monsieur le
québécois le premier ministre du québec
a interpellé vous ont été repérés en dix
ans ben oui il est qu à kyste ce qu'il
dit c'est que tout le monde qui n'est
pas caquistes n'est pas québécois
[Musique]
c'est odieux audio music
je sais pas si un dieu mais ils sont
plus surréaliste monsieur parce que
madame à anglet et tromper al hadi où le
dire monsieur le président vous avez
compris le dit monsieur québécois
monsieur legault hors micro a dit ben
oui c'est ce qu'avait couaillier cac et
sarah lamartine c'est parti les
fractures
l'horizon électoral on veut on veut bien
mettre la table de chacun de son cas
c'est intéressant ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui parce que le projet de loi
georges piel prochaine loi 96 sur la
langue ne crée pas beaucoup d'engouement
et quand même la protection de la langue
c'est un des piliers du
nationaliste de françois legault et on
cherchait une façon de titiller un peu
cette fibre là et on voyait aussi qu'ils
avaient une certaine fracture à
l'intérieur du caucus au sein du
gouvernement sur ce qu'on devait c'est
ce qu'on devrait aller plus loin par
exemple pour protéger la loi est ce
qu'on devait imposer la loi 101 au cégep
monsieur legault ne voulait pas les lots
ne veut pas aller là il ya mis un terme
aux débats mais on a l'impression que sa
position de compromis c'était de dire ok
on agrandira paul le cégep dawson même
si on l'avait défendu même c'est
démontré qu'un besoin là et son discours
c'est de dire on va privilégier les
francophones avant d'aller chez les uns
les anglophones et sa place et libéraux
dans une situation impossible parce que
il dépeint dominique anglade comme à la
tête du parti comme des anglophones et
lui dit merde moi je protège la majorité
mais elle il est dans une situation où
là évidemment la communauté anglophone
ce sont votre traditionnel elle pas
tellement juste de défendre cette
position là mais c'est très très dur on
voit de la stratégie michel avait du
côté de la caq du côté de monsieur
legault c'est clair et avance comme un
comme un bolide aux yeux là dessus le
portail web et web mais il fait du
rattrapage aussi
essaie de pallier la faiblesse comme
comme le disait martin la faiblesse de
son de son projet de loi et en
particulier son refus d'étendre la loi
101 au cégep part
nous tout à fait sûr le danseur qui
comme disait martin il y avait inclus
sort parmi les projets d'infrastructures
prioritaires dans son projet de loi 66
qui dans la nouvelle mouture de ce même
projet l'oeil c'était toujours là et il
avait
voté contre une motion où ils avaient
bloqué une motion qui demandait
justement d'annuler l'agrandissement du
cégep dawson et là tout d'un coup parce
qu'il se rend compte je pense que y est
en porte à faux avec la majorité en tous
cas francophones sur la question de la
loi 100 il fait du rattrapage
sur le fond je suis d'accord avec lui
dans ce ne devrait pas être agrandi mais
il reste que c'est de la politique les
normes peut-être qu'il faut les changer
mais en vertu des normes existantes le
collège dawson aurait droit
l'agrandissement à terme d'offrir 6 et
stéphanie c'est comme s'ils voulaient
vraiment cantonné madame anglais de
lâcher son électorat agglo fine avoue
que vous deux mois je m'occupais de tous
les francophones
mais c'est ça c'est ce qui est embêtant
c'est que monsieur leveaux 1 du business
quand même est étonnant parce que il ya
quelques jours où il ya laissé la vie a
laissé tomber son projet de contribution
financière pour les non vaccinés en nous
disant qu' il y avait déjà suffisamment
de de colère dans la population puiqu'il
voulait il voulait pas créer la folie de
la polarisation
mais par contre ils se hissent permet
quand même de de créer une polarisation
bien d'autres endroits comme on l'a vu
avec ceux des bols jeu c'est sûr que
pour lui c'est vraiment un
espèce de voix
laïcité langue française tout ce qui na
tion québécoise c'est le signe et le de
sa stratégie puis sa place ses
adversaires dans une position assez
compliqué parce que c'est comme qui a
réussi à 10 rebonds mais nous à la cac
on représente la nation québécoise ok il
ya des québécois qui peuvent très bien
ne pas être d'accord avec ses positions
et
est tout de même de véritables québécois
il n'a pas le monopole de 2,2 d'être
québécois et cac et québécois sont pas
sont pas des sons sont pas liées est
exclu pour le reste non électeurs
je peux peut-être le meilleur exemple
voulu enlever sa du chemin il dira je
vais choisir et comme visite michel davy
comme il voulait pas imposer au sujet d'
au moins frais au moins j'ai grandi les
pommes le plus grand cégep anglophone du
québec
mais où il ya beaucoup de francophones
qui vont le sait c'est l'autre débat
s'éternisera c'est terminé c'est terminé
bonne soirée à très bientôt pour voir
ou revoir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit